I jumped into modeling modeling was I
would say not necessarily the best thing
for someone's psyche not necessarily the
best thing for someone's image and and
their sense of self what you're being
hired to do is to be the spokesperson
for a particular image so then you find
yourself having to be kind of a
chameleon and you find yourself having
to change who you are and maybe you know
adhere to strict diet staying out of the
sun was something that they told me I
had to do so yeah I mean God literally
showed me the value of the world when it
got shut
[Music]
down what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at LED live we got an awesome
show for you today because we have a
very special guest her name is blessings
win and she has worked on music video
production behind the camera in front of
the camera she's going to tell us her
testimony her story of what got her into
that and how God got her attention and
actually pulled her out of that so I'm
really excited to get into this
blessings uh tell us a little bit about
yourself yeah sure thank you so much I'm
glad to be here um let's see I'll start
with uh where I was raised I was raised
in Berkeley California my parents are um
basically what what what you would call
hippies um my father was an Irish Jewish
German Scottish man who was a teacher um
an arbitrator and my mother is from the
Caribbean side of Nicaragua
um she was 7-Day Adventist raised and so
I had that you know Faith as my
upbringing my father however he was more
teetering toward the esoteric side you
know he's a product of the the 60s and
70s where you know um yoga and um
esoteric philosophy The Beatles were
really really key and so he definitely
had an esoteric leaning however he did
let my mom lead in in terms of raising
us in terms of our faith Faith so that
was really good I mean I got to know
Christ young so that was awesome yeah um
my father was like my best friend and um
loved him dearly we were really really
really close and growing up I looked at
him for everything and I didn't really
realize just how important he was in my
life until he became sick and um right
when I was about 9 months pregnant uh my
father had esophageal cancer and um I'll
get to that a little bit later but this
is this is all the things that were
starting to build up in the future that
I wasn't aware was going to happen and
so I was kind of just living life you
know in the sense of I'm young I'm going
to explore you know like world what's up
so um I jumped into modeling and um
modeling was you know I would say not
necessarily the best thing for someone's
psyche not necessarily the best thing
for someone's um image and and their
sense of self why would you say that
yeah can we unpack that a little bit
because I know there's a lot of people
that that have an sort of a glamorized
view of that business yeah well you know
modeling yeah you know you get to be on
you know you're the main image or the
face for something but in reality what
you're being hired to do is to be the
spokesperson for particular image and if
you don't fit that image then you're not
going to get that job so then you find
yourself having to be kind of a
chameleon and you find yourself having
to change who you are and maybe you know
adhere to strict diets adhere to you
know like one time someone told me don't
be in the sun because then we're not
going to be able to use you as much as
we would if you don't look white you
know and so staying out of the sun was
something that they told me I had to do
um you know there's a lot of like
negativity too right I mean I I spent a
little bit of time in in Hollywood and
and it's like 99% no you're not the
right person you don't look the right
part or whatever and so that plays on
your your you know poor self-image I
guess if you're just hearing constant
like you know wrong things about you
you're not you know you don't look black
enough you don't look Hispanic enough
you don't look white enough your hair is
too curly cuz I you know usually I have
my hair really curly but at this time
when I was modeling even though these
pictures are curly after this point I
stopped wearing my hair cly because I
was losing jobs you know really they
wanted me to look more quote unquote
white and so um well there's a lot of
Trends and fads maybe you were hot 10
years ago but that's not what we're
looking for anymore so like you're old
news then right and um so then in you
know after I graduated from college I
ended up um going to um Hollywood and so
I broke into Hollywood and I was there
about a month and my best friend who is
now one of the executives at Disney for
Buenavista pictures animation she and I
were just starting little you know
buling in in Hollywood and she says to
me hey I got a friend I want you to you
know meet and this guy happened to know
a producer or or a director I should say
and he was one of the hottest directors
at the time in the music uh video
industry and his name was Darren Grant
and so I did an interview with him and I
basically told him I'm the missing piece
to your puzzle you know like you need me
because I'm super creative and so he
said i' you know he'd never had anyone
say anything like that to him so he said
let me try you out you know so like
confidence that want him over exactly so
I went from being in front of the camera
to now standing behind the camera and I
I forgot to mention that when I was at
the University I went to a Jesuit
university so by the end of my four
years there my my faith was really
thrown off kilter
because the Bible wasn't you know a
teach instrument so I you know got to
Santa CL on a chemistry scholarship I
intended to be either a doctor or a
patent lawyer I decided I hate arguing
and I can't stand infectious disease so
I'm out you know and I switched my major
to communication with the tele
television production um emphasis so
that's how I ended up in Hollywood
switch Yeah Yeah huge switch Yeah so um
I'm not going to be a lawyer I might as
well be a model right right well I had
been since a child okay in all fairness
um but I was always a brainy kid you
know pretty smart kid so it was
definitely a path that I could have
pursued but this was more fun yeah so it
was a chemistry scholarship yes so I was
at Santa clar and was chemistry you too
yeah um Dolph lungren when he came to
the US he W had a full ride scholarship
to MIT for chemical engineering you
would not ever Peg that guy as like a
chemical engineer ing like brainy nerd
so while he landed in the US he went to
New York and did an audition and he
totally flipped his whole career from
that see and that's how it happens is
you know you get these opportunities and
and it's like you know you get pulled in
opposite oh this looks more glamorous
I'll do that more exciting and within
like I said within a month and a half
which is really really really rare you
don't go to Hollywood and then just you
know land a job like this hated those
stories right I know so so I was one of
the people who actually went there you
know it's not that I didn't do um I
never waitressed or anything but I did
work at a a post- production house as
basically a a glorified um Barista you
know so the guys would need caffeine and
I'd be the one pumping you know the
caffeine into them and and and a month
and a half later I landed this job and I
was basically how how the music video
system works is that the major um uh
record labels will mail out you know an
upcoming single of a promising or
already established artist and so of
course they were already established in
fact they were kind of starting to Trend
out um but they had a song called thank
you in advance and so the director and I
would sit together and we would listen
to this song on repeat and come up with
an idea like you know what's going to
happen you know what do you think this
song is really about and so it didn't
have anything to do with you being a
Jesuit trained
that you got the job as well but that's
interesting to me that they leave
sometimes that creativity in the hands
of I mean that just gets me what do you
guys think about this and what are you
going to do with that because look at
how many music videos have these like
really esoteric ideas right or you know
why if there's just people coming up
with those ideas how's that happening
you know I think there's a difference
though I will say because you know for
me I was just fresh ideas I was you know
coming in I wasn't necessarily hungry
and studying other people's works which
is what happens a lot when you're trying
to break into that industry you'll pick
someone and you'll say oh I want to you
know be able to you know create videos
like that guy and I totally was coming
in like just fresh blood yeah they love
fresh meat yeah exactly and and the the
rare I think the odd thing about my
experience in Hollywood was that you
know how you said it it's it's rare for
for you to get such a quick start but
for me I would show up on sets and and I
promise you it's not a pat on my back at
all I would literally get rolls on the
spot and I was really uncomfortable with
that because I knew that there was
something called you know the actor's
guild I knew that there were you know
these boundaries and I knew that if I
stepped in and did something like that
that I would automatically be like a
hated person and I also knew that it
came with with an exchange right and
usually those offers were sexual in
nature of course and um there is there
is a definite Drive in Hollywood to feed
an an
insatiable um quest for flesh and I saw
it all day you know and I just and
that's probably what kept me from going
back in front of the camera you know I
just said no I'd rather stand back here
because I don't have to deal with all
that right right right I I think don't
realize that as well I mean obviously
being a male I didn't experience that on
the same same level but I certainly had
friends and they all talked about it I
don't think there's one person that's
ever come through that system that
doesn't talk about that and he like yeah
you want roles and and I mean Harvey
Weinstein proved that right you look
back and and he starts dropping names of
all the people and you're like wait
she's famous she's famous she's famous
and they've all had to compromise
themselves in order for you know them to
have the screen time so I always make
that I call to young people especially
like there's a girl in in my church now
who really wanted to go to Hollywood her
dad came and approached me knew that I'd
been there and he asked me my opinion I
said dude I would never ever ever send
my daughter into that Lion's dead never
and you're really stripping away a a
very important time you know the Bible
says train up a child in the way he
should go and if you train him up in
this this is the way that child will go
right and and so you know yes it would
be odd to see an adult play a kid you
know but and I understand the need for
children act you know child actors but
you have to be so diligent about being
by their side 24/7 not letting them out
of your sight because the industry is
just really not a place for kids and not
even a place for young women yeah I mean
someone who's gr grown up in the
business like if it was up to Raven
Simone to write the law the internet
laws of parenting and children like what
would be some healthy boundaries that
you think people should follow that's a
really loaded question dude I don't
believe any child should be on TV or
recorded until after they turn 10 years
old use AI for all I care I just don't
think it's necessary I think that before
you put your child in the industry there
needs to be a psychologist
psychiatrist um assessing the
parents uh beforehand and if you get
assessed and they need a child then yeah
you can you can put your child on
younger than then I truly believe that
the parent should not be the managers of
the children the parents should
be the parents the parents and also keep
a job and not live off the child while
the child is working to then make the
child feel like if they don't work the
family's going to disperse cougan law
needs to be stronger and I also believe
there needs to be a school I believe
that there needs to be a Institution for
children and their parents before they
get into the industry so that they
understand the laws they understand the
secret laws and they understand
professionalism when it comes to working
in the industry Roman palansky right he
had somebody drop a kid off at his house
I mean I've heard that story time and
time again there was a young lady who
was and he fled right to to evade
persecution was a young girl that was
part of um some superhero movie I
remember kind of looking at that clip
and she all of a sudden came out and she
was saying like she was being pressured
to go alone to these people's houses and
she's like no she's like 13 years old no
I'm not going to do that and like that
was her exit but a lot of kids will stay
you know especially the kids that come
from like broken homes or the kids that
you know have really low self-esteem or
or again didn't have any principled you
know uh guidelines for their life so
they'll stay and they'll tolerate that
because the fame and attention they get
they perceive it as love and sometimes
the adults are encouraging and complicit
absolutely you think of like Brook
Shields she was like 14 yes they were
they were doing topless and terrible
things like that and it's like where's
her parents at our mom was there yeah
yeah she was mindboggling like you can
do a photo shoot like that but it's
highly easy and I think some parents
live vicariously through this and some
make a living off these children it's
the same with like Kim Kardashian you
know like her well her mom being
invested in that you know has been
pushing all the way sick and the whole
family you know and it and it you know
not to have negative conversation about
that family but I really wonder like
what's going on with the kids you know
because they're so busy you know
creating stories to keep them you know
pertinent
and I I don't see how they're spending
quality time with these young kids true
so I'm super curious like um what kind
of creativity did you actually put in
these these uh music videos do you look
back on it now and do you go oh where
did that thought come from and I
wouldn't have done that today or you
know you know honestly just listening
this one it was all about creating a
situation because the song is about you
know I'm thanking you in advance for all
the things that you're going to give me
in our lives right so our first child
our marriage even to the point of you
know me having to attend your funeral
that's really sad to say but that's how
the video went and so I'm pulling in my
mind all these images of someone who's
foretelling the future in a sense in a
romantical sense not in a mystical sense
but in the way that a lover would say
can't wait to grow old with you yeah
yeah so that was really the basis for
This One MH yeah that seemed rather mild
compared to some of them are oh yeah no
no no
and um you know this this is a a shot
from U the Survivor video so if we go
back you know Destiny's Child was like
this big big hit at the time um they had
one song that did really well and it was
a remix it no it was the remix with
whitecliffe and because they weren't
doing that great but when he remixed
them then they started getting some
traction yeah and so then what happened
was the the original for broke up and
then they had just the two Kelly Roland
and Beyonce they then found two other
girls um or one at the time Michelle
Williams and they were the reformulated
you know 2.0 Destiny's Child and so the
video was I'm a Survivor and it spoke to
the challenges of being a music artist
losing you know um your bandmates and
then still being able to survive and so
when we got the record in the mail um it
was pretty clear you know okay these
women are they're tough they they
they're survivors but how can we make it
not so much about conflict between the
women in the group but more about we are
you know per we persevere and so I came
up with an idea of them being ship
Shipwrecked and this is like the temple
temple dance but um so did you come up
with the temple SC so yes so in
storyboard you sit with the storyboard
artist you give them your treatment you
sit with them and you tell them this is
my vision this is what I want you know
to happen here here and there because to
be honest if I saw this I'd be like look
this is Illuminati they're doing some
ritual sacrifice here Temp and see and
that's the crazy thing I know and that's
the crazy thing because at this point in
my life it had nothing to do with that
it's just that sh they were Shipwrecked
and where would they you know be
shipwreck wrecked at that we could have
a stage is kind of what I was thinking
this is the part that that that I'm I'm
I really try to wrap my head around
because people always have this question
is everybody sitting in this room trying
to like deceive you yeah it's like
what's going on here I think the
inspiration comes from many different
areas and I don't think people
understand where that inspiration comes
from and and it also depends too on the
artist because if they were um and at
this point I mean this isn't Beyonce yet
you know what I mean this isn't who she
is yet this is in their beginning stages
before they are indoctrinated into
Hollywood and the mithraism and and the
religion
you know I know she's like straight
worshiped at this point there's people
that like like have a religion around
her well but she also promotes her own
religion which is Ura epha and when you
watch her videos now you'll see direct
you know pointings to the gods that she
serves so like osun the river goddess um
so so so let me ask you this you talked
about the filtration system really
basically of Hollywood of like you
compromising right it seems like a first
sort of fil filter of people getting in
the door is sexual in nature right if
you'll say yes you're you're you're kind
of compromising for this so is beyond
say someone that's just compromised in
those areas to the Max and it's like the
compromise gets to the level of
basically you're compromising which God
you're serving you know honestly when I
was working with her at this point now I
wasn't working intimately with her you
know I'm more of like creative behind
the scenes right creative behind the
scenes I did give her some you know
advice during the video during the beach
scenes um which her Camp wasn't too
happy about you know like because it was
very clear they were going to make her
like the star that she would have a
definite solo career um and I would say
that at this point she was still they
were praying in circles you know
together praying to Jesus wow um I don't
believe that at this point any of that
was going on but again I'm not behind
the scenes in her life I can't really
speak to that but I can say that the
Beyonce that we now see is not the
Beyonce that was praying to Jesus when
she first started yeah but I think it's
just a filtration system of the more
that those people con like compromise
it's like the people that make it and
bubble to the top are like the ultimate
compromisers oh absolutely you I mean
yeah because no one's going to give you
the king the keys to the kingdom unless
you represent that Kingdom right and
it's a it's a demonic Kingdom I
understand it like from God's
perspective he's putting in place his
ministers and his people to share his
messages and he's orchestrating that
behind the scenes the devil's just
counterfeiting that with his ministers
he has his own disciples you think about
the funneling system and and we talked a
lot about this that what the ration
relationship is between a man and a
woman if you'll break that
representation it's it's so such a
metaphor it's ultimately selfish for
breaking that relationship with God
right if you break that one it every
other step is so much easier easier
because a marriage really truly is how
can I um you know please this other
person whereas like this is flipping
that system upside down on its head it's
like porn right I'm going to get
something out of this and I don't care
what happens or or what the reasons are
for me to do that the more selfish you
are the more self- minded you are the
more successful so his ministers become
ultimate selfishness to the point where
you would let people worship you over
God that you know of Satan doesn't care
how he gets you and when you look at
like I should probably pull it up but if
you look at um like Matthew chapter 7
right the Bible always essentially when
it looks at what's going on at the end
of time it's always dividing people into
two groups not everyone who says to me
Lord Lord shall enter the Kingdom of
Heaven both groups are Christian right
yeah both groups are professing the name
of Christ both groups are saying yeah
this is my God that's who I'm praying to
this is my mind is is on that and you
know it continues to go on it says but
he who does the will of my Father in
heaven what's the difference between the
two groups one's doing God's will oneing
own and what is the will of God that's
where like somebody comes to him and
goes what's the greatest commandment
right love love God yeah love your
neighbor with all you know love your
neighbor as yourself and love God with
all your mind heart and soul right which
is others focused look at what some of
these people are doing to get to that
well they've Rewritten the decalog and
it's no longer about you know love
thyself at all really it it's it's not
what they're doing isn't really love
what they're doing is just it's a it's a
distorted view of love and it's one that
says I can be God and I can be worshiped
so they've like you said they've they
flipped it and so will these be the
people that go and say Lord Lord you
know and he said say get from me I never
knew you yes but the people who I mean
it's just really hard to be in this
environment and and hold fast to your
Christian values that's interesting what
you just said there because you were
talking about parents who are living
vicariously through their kids like I
wanted to be a model so you got to be a
model y Satan doesn't really manifest in
front of people and have people bowing
down before him but he's getting the
worship vicariously through these
celebrities like when when you go to
Beyonce concert they're all lifting
their hands if I could just touch her
never watch well and they're coming into
Beyonce like she says with Sasha Fierce
right and they're worshiping her so
they're really are woring but they're
just yeah they're just disguising it as
a person he doesn't care how he how he
gets you it's like if you're not
worshiping God you're worshiping right
there there's there's no neutral place
there's only two branches and the branch
is either you're with God or you're for
Satan and people really believe that
there's this like neutral Zone and they
call that neutral zone new age but
that's complete deception the other way
yeah this is um Craig David and so he
was big in the US around the 20002 2002
Mark he is at that point he was the
equivalent of of Justin Timberlake but
for the UK okay so he was actually
extremely Pleasant to work with he was
like one of the people that I would just
no matter what say this was a good solid
K like you know no matter who was on the
set no matter who was working he was
asking you how are you yeah just how are
you everything okay you know not a
ferocious person at all and most people
in this environment are disgusting oh
yeah they're Divas they're deos padas I
I was in Samuel French one day do you
remember what the place was where had
all the scripts and stuff like that and
um right after I walked out Michael
Jackson walked in and I was like oh I
wanted to see m
Jackson but he he had a producer that
walked in front of him and was like
don't look at him don't look at him they
booted everybody out and like you know I
was like don't look at him and I
remember I remember I think um I worked
on a show with um what's the guy that's
always always on Oprah the
doctor Dr Phil's like that too on the
show that we worked at they walked
around to the production and they were
like don't look at him don't look at him
when he walks by don't look at him and I
was like what do you what do you mean
don't look at the guy like does see
those reptilian eyes exposed you know
and I think honestly um it's it's kind
of one of these
very weird vacuum Fishbowl situations
where they want so badly to be respected
heralded worshiped but then it comes at
a cost where you can't turn it off
there's no off switch for that exactly
you can't go to the grocery store if
you're Michael Jacks no you can't buy
things you know that are that to you and
I are normal like toilet paper and be a
star you'll be ridiculed if you actually
spent time with a celebrity like Real
Time With That Celebrity and observed
how their life really is I I don't think
the average person would say oh that
looks so much fun I want to do that I
mean really it's like you have this
glamorized view of it but I think it is
a fishbowl and it's it's golden
handcuffs well the other thing too is
that it it promotes a narcissistic yeah
personality and so many people I think
already have a leaning toward that
tendency because you can't possibly want
to endure thish for what you're really
getting which is no more privacy
isolation in a lot of ways everybody
talking smack about you how many
celebrities have they dropped off the
end after their career is done I mean
it's like everybody they yeah they they
take daggers at and then it becomes
protecting your kingdom yeah you can't
get away from it no yeah I remember once
I've told you about this um it was in
the red Wood National Forest so North of
San Francisco visting some of my wife's
relatives we're out in one of these
national parks and I'm looking and I'm
like man that guy looks really
familiar I'm like I tell my wife I was
like that looks like the guy from The
Sopranos which one the main guy James G
and so I went over I know anything about
that show and I was like I was like I'm
going to just go over and and like check
and and like see if this is him right
like the guy can't escape
I wasn't but over and he I like you know
I like you look a lot like the guy from
The Sopranos he's like there's a good
reason for that I was like you sound
like him too he's like there's a good
reason for that and so then I was like
trying to get a picture yeah you know
cuz that's that's just human nature
right we see celebrity we want and it's
like I got to show my friends or
whatever but that was super kind he
wasn't inviting you to harass him but at
the same time he wasn't denying was
declined me yeah um I think he was with
his kid and like a producer or something
but I just I remember walking away from
that me like you can't get away like it
doesn't matter where the middle of the
forest there's
no and and if and if you know you work
on something that actually people
dislike you which is possible I mean you
can do something that people will all of
a sudden turn on you there's no turn off
of that either and people people have
like these terrible lives after like
everybody hates on them because some
part they play or whatever you know and
I forgot to mention that before I landed
this job you know for that month and a
half and I was working as a barista at
the post Production Studio I was going
on you know go SE because I was modeling
and I was also you know auditioning for
you know commercials and whatever I
could you know get my hands on and I
remember I got a call for um basically a
werewolf oh yeah like so I read for the
part wait you were playing a werewolf I
was supposed to be this like part of
this band of like a a gang okay um and
so I had to practice with my agent he
says you've got it like go and my
inspiration for this werewolf role was
actually The Exorcist because when I was
six that movie had come out like a year
or two earlier and then it was put on
regular TV and I remember that my
siblings were watching it and I snuck
out of my room
because I just wanted to be involved not
knowing what was going to be on TV that
night and I Saw Linda Blair in the worst
you know it was awful and to this day
there are times and spaces where I can't
be in a tight space because of the
things I saw in that film but
nonetheless I use that inspiration
excuse me for this role and it got me
three callbacks to where I ended up
meeting with the director and I think
God intervened because what I found out
was that it was actually going to be um
the role Angel Dark Angel which is
what's her name um Jessica
Alba's role right wow and and that was
one of the times that they told me you
know don't tan don't this you know like
when by the time you get in front of the
director I want you to look you know
Ambiguously white you're going to be
dark angel but don't too dark they
probably told her the same thing yeah
they probably did and so I think
honestly I really believe that God
intervened because when I sat with the
director I did my exorcise bit and he
loved it and then he was like okay well
now do it with a valley girl accent and
I'm from California so I mean like it's
totally fine I can do that but for
whatever reason I couldn't do it I
couldn't do it interesting I could not
yeah and so I left there going that's
like my back pocket like how did I not
you know and so I think I do believe
looking back that the Holy Spirit was
like no this isn't for you this isn't
the life that I have can I ask you a
weird question because I used to do this
all the time so I'm curious of your
answer um did you ever have a thought or
conversation with god if I get this part
I'll give you the money or I'll I'll
I'll I'll do something glorious for you
no I used to make deals with God like
that all the time and it's like now I
think about it and like you know whether
I tried out for some werewolf part or
whatever
I think I I think I auditioned for um
the Scooby-Doo one and uh uh I was like
you know supposed to be a stoner and
this and that God help me yeah God help
me get this part that would get a stoner
part for the what am I doing I honestly
I don't believe that I ever did I wasn't
I I wasn't sold out to Hollywood in that
way I was always a creative and so being
in front of the camera wasn't
necessarily my and especially after
seeing what the talent would do in order
to get like front you know camera time I
was like well that was probably a fresh
perspective to them to you then you know
it's like you were able to like Excel
because maybe you came at it from that
from that perspective where other people
are like pick me pick me pick me please
pick me so this was also another one
this is what from my camera this is 3lw
and you could see like back in the day
you know when it wasn't digital and you
took like your camera and you would
print everything out and this was in pad
Del Carmen we flew to Mexico and it's it
was a beautiful location on the beach
and um I went on a scout with one of our
scouting directors and and um we ended
up uh finding this really cool Cenote
you guys know what a Cenote is it's like
a where you see a cave with the water
fresh water and fish and all that so we
found one of these really cool cotas and
so we built a stage on top of that and
it was going to be a place another
location for them to dance at oh this
was U jumping back Craig David and this
was like his his right hand his best
friend um and me in the middle um I
actually ended up being talent for this
as well I was the DJ in the video funny
cool they had me Cameo and in fact for
the for the Survivor video I also had to
even though I wasn't a standin you know
I was literally part of the production
team um one of the the girls freaked out
um Michelle Williams freaked out being
in the ocean so I had to then put on her
outfit and double as her um walk in the
ocean right so some when you're in
production though you have to do
whatever's required need to get done you
need to get it done and this is in um
Los felis this is where we filmed and so
you could see kind of in the background
this is our story boards and so it's
listed there so that we were're sure to
get the shots that you know we've we've
designed what years were these so this
is between 99 till 2002 okay so I was
there I moved there in '99 February 99
and I was there till 2009 so I was there
about the same time you were there yeah
I skedaddled because I ended up getting
engaged and so I was having a
longdistance relationship with um my now
husband he was in Florida I was in
California and so then after that I
started doing um basically freelancing
and so directors would you know call me
or email me yeah and they'd say hey I
got this video coming up you know you
think you can shoot me something and I'd
type something up you know
um so more moments and so the company
that we worked for it was called aand
aart it's now defunct but it was Michael
Bernar Lawrence Bender Quinton Tarantino
we were on the first floor music video
and commercials first floor second floor
I forget what it was but I think third
floor was movies so they were
responsible for like um the Mexican The
Usual Suspects you know like so we had
Heavy Hitters in our production house
there was definitely um you know a
viable one so I mentioned you know I was
dating and so my um now husband and I we
were dating for three years and um he
was working his way excuse me his way up
through the miners and he ended up um
securing a job with the in the expansion
um basically that was the Devil Rays who
are now just the Rays in Florida and um
is a sports MLB sorry MLB Major League
Baseball so he was you know moving his
way up and right around the time that he
yeah he secured his job with um the
majors with uh Tampa Bay we got married
that offseason these are my parents and
my husband and I and um right as we
finished our wedding and flew to our
honeymoon we got a call saying that uh
the manager of Seattle Lou Panella had
been traded for my husband and that's
super rare you don't hear of manager
being traded for a baseball player right
and so he actually it only had happened
one time before in history and it had
been like 40 years 60 years prior and
this was the first time in a long time
wow so this led us into a um you know a
totally different trajectory um now my
environment is a different cast of
celebrities it's you know Sports
celebrities so we had uh my first our
first
Sadia right around the time that she was
13 months old um my father was diagnosed
with esophageal cancer stage for and so
it was like you know you've got four to
six weeks to live you know you're you're
done you know and it was really really
difficult because again like I said this
was my best friend this was I mean he
was my everything he still did my taxes
even though you know we had plenty of
money to be able to Outsource it um and
so at the time that um my son was about
to be born so a month before my son was
born my father passed and that was a
really really difficult time um the boy
at the top that's my nephew and we had
adopted him when he was 12 so when I was
pregnant with her um and I was really
really suffering you know um it may not
look like it in these photos but I was
really really you know just grieving and
and down and out and I remember a friend
of mine said you know she was a
Christian teammate her husband was a
teammate of my husbands and she said um
you know there's this guy he's a Healer
he can help you and so I was like you
know help heal sounds good to me you're
Christian I trust you exactly sign me up
let's go and um and I went and he told
me things about myself that nobody do
and and I was like this guy's got a gift
you know like he's the real deal that's
how they win your
confidence and so
um that led to me leaning on him for
support you know he started speaking to
me in in Christian
terms and he himself was raised Catholic
so he was you know familiar with the the
lingo you know the bacular of Christian
you know Holy Spirit you know
forgiveness all these things and oh you
must be a good guy yeah exactly so I
didn't have the discernment to say you
know he's a wolf and sheep's clothing
you know and so um I really leaned on
him I just I know that he would do
things to me that I was completely
ignorant of the reality behind what they
really were so for instance he would say
to me you know I know that things are
really hard things that you know you got
a lot on your hands you got your you
know now you got your mom to take care
of you got your two kids and your nephew
you know your husband's traveling and at
this time we're with the giant San
Francisco Giants and so he's like you
just need to be reset that was his
terminology you just need to be reset so
he's like let's just do some breathing
exercises you know so I'm doing these
breathing exercises with him and then he
would say okay just undulate your spine
so I'm like inhale raise your chest
exhale you know curve forward and it was
about you know seven or eight
undulations like this and then he would
say hold your breath and then he would
hit my chest
and I would black out what and when I
would come to I would feel like I was
trembling um but I would also feel like
nothing mattered everything was okay oh
no you know it was just like kind of
like a a bliss kind of kind of feeling
you know and I didn't know what that was
I didn't know um and as our relationship
progressed he started speaking Less in
Christian terms and More in Buddhist and
Hindu terms but I was still none the
wiser because that wasn't something yeah
that wasn't a Doctrine I you're not
familiar with it right yeah right so
this is my niece and my niece is from
New York and she's my older sister
Gloria's daughter and we are exactly 18
years apart and she had come out to
California and I was thinking you know
my husband and I were like we're going
to save her you know get her out of New
York we're doing something great for
this kid you know she's going to go to
to a post back for medical school and
we're doing something good you know by
her that was our mentality well she was
the only practicing Christian in our
home at that time because our my husband
and I were from two different faith
faiths and we really couldn't agree he
he's a Sunday church kind of guy I'm a
Sabbath you know and so we really
couldn't agree and for me it was like
I'm I'm not willing to compromise I
tried Sunday just I know the truth I
can't do it you know it's just really
difficult he's a great guy it has
nothing to do with you know him it's
just what is your biblical understanding
right so this whole time she's with us
for about five years and then covid
hits and when the pandemic struck see
and at this time I forgot to mention I
became a yoga student um a teacher you
know they they said oh you'd be a great
teacher you know I grew up dancing so
I'm really flexible and before you know
it I got all mixed up in this yoga world
and I started to practice spiritualism
but I I was branding it Christian
interesting I hope our audience hears
this I hope I hope I hope you hear this
because we talk about this all the time
it's like people get into spiritualism
through a door that they do not realize
they don't even understand it and it's
like this is the reason here's the
reason right here
reason I'm a walking testimony don't
open that door yeah anytime someone says
to you
healer whoo you should have like alarm
Bells sounding in your head anyone says
spiritual right yeah you know I just
didn't I was none the wiser I just
didn't know so that was the Gateway and
then it led to yoga and then yoga just
started to open cuz that Community is
woo yeah yeah what I didn't like about
yoga I remember engaging in it a few
times when I was there in Los Angeles I
did not like this repetitive thing and
then it was seemed like your mind just
went away and then they're saying words
that I don't understand never liked that
yeah I was just like I feel
uncomfortable about this and I well the
thing too about it was that I just saw
it as exercise and I I had been
certified my first yoga 200 hour yoga um
certification was with a company called
Core Power Yoga and they're pretty much
a chain all over right and so it just
kind of looks like oh this is like this
new hot exercise where they they you
know kick up the temperature and you're
just going to go in there stretch and
and sweat you know and that's all I
thought it was I had no idea that it was
an actual Seance it's it's a it's a
moving worship of Hindu deities I had no
idea but then you you're trying to get
into these contortion you know just
weird positions and even though I was
flexible I was like like how do I get my
foot there and my chin there and my back
here you know what I mean so then I
started looking into what the yogis say
to get better trying to get better and
then now I'm sucked into the vas and the
upad and and all the the Hindu
scriptures and now I'm reading the
bagita you know and it's wow it's it was
wild I had no idea I thought that I was
strong enough to stay
Christian and see the devil for when he
came and I I couldn't I couldn't because
they've Stripped Away everything that
would give you an alarm yeah from yoga
like you said you go in you have no idea
what they're saying they're talking in
Sanskrit which is a spiritual language
specific to this type of worship and the
deity that they serve right so she was
the only practicing Christian in my home
she was keeping Sabbath
and you know she would invite me and at
this point you know I'm also teaching
dance so Sabbath I
remember um I was teaching a class on
Saturday knowing that I was doing you
know against what that little voice but
it's kind of like in it kind of reminds
me of when you said you know God if you
would just that was my moment you know
what I mean like God if you would just
you know let me get this class cuz it's
like a group of 60 people
I'll use it for you instead of making
mantras we we'll say Bible vers exactly
and it was just you know just I was
confused and so when Co hit the world
shut down which meant that all my jobs
shut down right because I had hung up my
writing job my production job my ghost
writing job and I had taken myself into
fitness and so now the clubs are closing
you know and I worked at all the
high-end clubs and I said to myself hm
I'm going to get a Pelon I'm going Ride
This Out you know what I mean I really
thought I was going to be able to just
ride my bike through the storm thinking
of my health but I wasn't thinking my
spiritual health and this is where this
woman comes in and saves me beautiful
wow because she was nonjudge judgmental
and I was doing meditation and still
doing yoga on the low on my own and then
it all out of nowhere it just was like
not working and I became full of anxiety
and I was not myself like my personality
went flat I was trembling I couldn't eat
there
was like a a spiritual oppression that
had just consumed me
and I couldn't even enjoy my fa family I
couldn't I couldn't do anything and my
niece was just would you like me to pray
with you do you want to come you know
with me to worship you know we can turn
on a
sermon and so we started doing that and
um Slowly by slowly it was like I'd come
out 5 10 minutes you know then I go back
to my closet and I'd read my Bible and I
mean I was on my knees begging God I'd
never experienced anything like this and
I had no idea what it was and so over
the months of Co there were a lot of
things going on and one of the things
that I did was I called the spiritual
Guru and I said can you explain what's
going on like you know what is this
about and so he drew parallels with
Jesus's pre crucifixion story and he
said do you remember how when the Jews
wanted him or barabus over him and I
said yes he said do you remember when
Pontius you know interviewed Jesus and
he knew that he was you know King of the
Jews he knew he was the Christ but he
said I'm going to wash my hands of this
he said that's what we're doing right
now he said welcome to the end of the
world wow and it like killed me right I
was like so then I had this
momentary like laughter where I was like
I'm just going to go have fun that's all
that matters you know that was my thing
and then I totally just crashed wow wow
and at that same time you had the
presidential election the the drama
between Obama and excuse me Obama
leaving um Biden and Trump and then you
had black lives matter I mean the world
was just in chaos up then there was a a
a documentary on the cabal and the
elites I don't know if you guys heard
about that very dark dark 10p part
series wow a girl A girlfriend of mine
said she had watched it and she's a
she's a victim of child like molestation
and and abuse and so that's what this is
about and supposedly like the clintons
and all these people Pizza gate or you
know that whole conspiracy and out of
Shadows was a good out of Shadows right
so this is a that line was it Wayfair
Wayfair wasn't like another thing when
they were like selling the kids using
the like pillows and stuff like that I
didn't see that I didn't know about that
one but so the world is in just conflict
and and it's adding to my oppressed
Spirit wow and
then whatever Spirit my Guru was using
on me started to show itself in my house
oh wow and I remember laying on this
therapeutic map that I had on the
floor and I was in a yoga position supat
canasa so your feet are together your
knees are bent so you're kind of like
that and um and I had fallen asleep
and out of nowhere I felt something grab
both of my ankles snatch my legs
straight to where both of my knees
popped like hyper you know flexed and
then I got dragged off my mat oh wow and
I woke up and I was like why am I off my
M you know what I mean like what's going
on like I felt that it was visceral I
didn't dream that that was real so this
Apparition kept showing up and kept
haunting me then I was levitating out of
my body without my
even like wanting to do it I didn't
provoke it like I don't I didn't know
what was going on so by this time um you
know I was getting I was studying to get
re-baptized and I was going through the
fundamentals you know the 28
fundamentals and um we started to watch
um my kids started watching Doug
Bachelor and we got where the church was
open so we started going to Granite Bay
oh beautiful 2 hours you know away
that's actually where my wife and I when
we left Los Angeles that was the church
we attended as the grand a wonderful
yeah it's a wonderful church and you
know we would make the
commute my my niece my mom my two kids
and I every Sabbath and 4H hour you know
commute and that happened for about
seven months wow that's a serious
commitment yeah it was for seven months
we did that that's how interested you
were in getting connected back I was
like Lord save me because he by now he's
rebuilding me he's starting to shut
these doorways down my yoga Alliance is
gone I'm now starting to read the
scriptures where it's telling me you
know don't buy into asceticism don't
think that you can worship angels and be
saved you know don't believe in
necromancy don't believe in witchcraft
you know all these things that I just
didn't know were the exact things the
Bible said don't do yeah it's not just
some old story that happened Way Long
it's like relevant to us today and so
many people get involved in it and and
man it's like like people don't know
what they're playing with this is this
is a beautiful story an example I'm glad
you were you know so honest and open and
sharing with us because people need to
hear this it's not playing around with
exercise no it's not and so later I I
came to
know literally while I was researching
and building the program um which is how
I met Mikey for 3abn dare to dream the
network um that you know Ivonne had
reached out after I came and did my
testimony she said the Lord has
impressed me that you should be the one
to do this new series for us so
beautiful I said let me pray on it and
that was like in May and by September I
told her yes and so for the fall the
whole next year I was researching all of
this you know not just I mean looking at
my yoga books everything cuz I also went
you know to an asham and lived in South
um carola in uh South India and learned
from a third generation meditation Guru
you know so you weren't just a weaken
Warrior no no no no I left my family and
I was gone you know like I was I was
into it did you still consider yourself
a Christian absolutely oh are you
kidding me at no point did I say I'm
Hindu I'm I'm Buddhist no I was like I'm
Christian and that's the thing is they
don't tell you who the God is yeah they
just call it Universe I I I think
Satan's very smart with branding his
form of religion with like oh there's a
there's a bunch of gods you can whatever
you can worship all these different gods
together and I think the reason why
Jesus was like only God Only God yes
there's only one and you need to worship
only one and see and even with all my
experience and living in India and and
you know getting trained by authentic
you know uh relatives of people who are
founders in this religious practice they
at no point did they say these are our
pantheons of
gods this is actually you know
um Transcendental Meditation none of
that none of that was disclosed it was
just this is ayurvedic solution to
disease this is the types of breathing
you can do to help you relax remove
stress you could do this to lose weight
you could do you know what I mean it was
like remedy related it was never these
are our Gods because the one thing that
the devil really also understands is
just like Jesus right how do you get to
somebody and how do you convert them oh
you help them physically first he spent
more time running around healing people
why because that's a great door into
somebody accepting whatever yeah
religious ideas that you have so at no
point was it and even with Core Power
none of this stuff I mean it was just
they did such such a meticulous job of
separating the Demonic from what looked
like
exercise so I was just out there and
thinking I was Christian and then
finally when I started like I said
reading the Bible it was revealed to me
just how Wayward and how I had just been
whing myself to all of these different
deities sorry to use that word but the
Bible the truth it right it's the truth
of it yeah Steps step by by step one
thing I've been really kind of thinking
about a lot is the life of Solomon
Solomon was this really brilliant guy
because you know he asked God for
discernment essentially to be able to
judge between his people and God gave it
to him but that didn't prevent Solomon
who knew better who had to write out the
entire law by hand who had to study it
all the days of his life it didn't
prevent him from going astray you're
right and the same thing happens with
Eve and with Solomon it's like a slow
progression right it's a slow fate it's
a drift it's a you know it's one step
then another step then another step but
you take Eve and her mind is more
perfect than Solomon's and happen like
that I think the the struggle that that
us men have honestly between Adam and
Eve right Eve was just straight up like
what this thing talks like how in the
world does it talk Adam sat there and
went like no I fully comprehend what you
just did give me the fruit anyway you
know what I mean it's like like we
struggle with that knowing and thinking
that we know and therefore somehow you
know we can dabble it's a catch 22
because the beauty of it that we don't
recognize is that God unlike the gods
and deities of other
religions the god that created
everything he gave us a
a moral autonomy he gave us the right to
believe we're not his slaves so he gives
us choice and he says here's my law but
it's up to you cuz I don't want you to
feel like I forced you to love me or
respect or obey me knowing the truth is
not what saves you I like that it's
following that's right obedience yeah
following ultimately following Jesus you
know who says I am the way the truth and
the life that's right but you have to
follow you have to have follow through
you can can know all kinds of things
Solomon knew yeah and it didn't prevent
him from going astray in fact the end of
his life he says that was a complete
waste of time and I should have done it
God's way isn't James the one that
pinned um don't just be a hearer of the
word but the doer as well yeah so just
the knowing the knowledge of isn't
enough it's like oh well the Bible tells
me to stare clear of that it's like do
it simple example is like you can know
that if you touch a stove it will burn
you yeah but if you don't believe that
it doesn't matter if you don't if you
don't practice that restraint guess what
you're going to get burnt you're going
to get it yeah and I mean it's to your
point he says if you love me what keep
my Commandments and all of this you know
the world is just I mean you become
consumed by the flesh you know and you
just you want to taste you want to you
know you want to see you want to feel
and and I'm I'm also not mad that God
allows us to explore because when I was
a a Christian without trial his word
kind of
was seemed a little heady seemed a
little I don't know what you mean there
right but then when I actually was
adulterous and and I was out there
living in the projection of evil and I
came back to the word then it was like
aha so in the same way that happened
with Solomon right he's God gave him
wisdom but guess what wisdom comes by
trying and living and so I'm not saying
go out there and do every bad deed you
know that's not my point at all right
but just know that you've never gone too
far right God can turn you around right
right and and he he did turn Solomon
around yes he did and he turned manasse
around who was oh my good even in a
worse position than Solomon in some ways
right right there's many examples in the
Bible of people that have done
absolutely awful things probably worse
than any of us and come back and so you
know there's always a moment that God
will so that's that's this moment here
and so I have it just it's beautiful to
me but you know she she told me so when
she had moved into our
home um we we have a guest bedroom
that's an on Suite downstairs and so we
equipped it with everything she could
imagine right her first night there she
said that she was harassed spiritually
things were coming out of a
mirror right she said you know I don't
know what's in your house but you know
and so I'm thinking and at this time I'm
not reading my Bible this is you know
preco I'm still out in the world I'm
I've opened portals and these Spirits
are in my home um t as a side comment my
kids I had them in a Waldorf School so I
actually wrote a book about this
interesting Waldorf School is what a
Magic School
pretty much it's it's a p school okay oh
my but I had again I didn't know I I
didn't know what witchcraft look like so
Waldorf schools what were made by a guy
named um Rudolph Steiner and Rudolf
Steiner was a Nazi sympathizer he
created a religion called anthroposophy
and he started at schools called waldor
schools or freethinking school or
Steiner schools and they are everywhere
and it's literally an a cult school and
so my when I enrolled my kids in that my
daughter started telling me there's a
woman walking around at night in a white
dress and again I'm going what what is
wrong with my family you know like
they're seeing things and wow you know
and I had opened these portals yeah but
they knew not to scare me they knew not
to come from me cuz you'll go straight
back into the church yes and so everyone
else is having these experiences
and I didn't have it until I left yoga
and when I left that's when they started
that's when I'm getting pulled off
that's when I'm levitating that's when
all these things are happening and so
you know my conscience said go and tell
your students yeah uh they were not
receptive oh I bet of course not yep no
I I remember we you know we did a
project on on martial arts which kind of
had a tie into yoga and a bunch of other
Eastern influences from Eric Wilson and
he was a teacher of martial arts and
same thing when he told his students it
was not receptive at all and he was
actually teaching I think it was in a
Christian uh martial arts class so I
mean it wasn't even that it was like
this far out you know like somebody
coming to you out of the blue I mean
they had done you know Christianity
basically with it and he came out with
with what he had researched and what he
had seen too as well and was just like
guys this is this is this is Sun worship
and this is whatever and they all one by
one like no and you open one door and
basically it it's snowballs I was still
teaching yoga I was still in that world
and when you're in that
world there's a lingo that goes with
everything there's a superficiality
that's in there you know you you pay for
your peace right so you pay for your
yoga class you you walk around your
peace is holding your mat and practicing
every day your piece is buying your yoga
clothes and looking cute in class your
piece is knowing how to get into the
posture and hold it longer than anybody
else your piece is it's all exterior
it's all work like a club it is exactly
it's all you know um this fake humility
and this I've arrived you know and all
of all of us were broken and none of us
were willing to admit it because we were
all wrapped up in some spiritualism That
was supposed to be solving our issues
and none of it was wow how long ago was
this so this uh Co was what
2019 so that was the end of it for me
2019 so 2020 you started really having a
serious walk back towards God but you
said even after you went back to church
you were still teaching yoga like what
no no no I I was done cu the world had
just you know okay there was noach
that's true and you're in California at
this time so yeah together was not an
easy thing it wasn't happening that's
why I bought the Pelon I thought like
I'm going be fine you know clubs are
shut but I got my bike you know wow um
and slowly you know God really I mean I
was so fearful and anxious and and and
riddled with spiritual you know
harassment and I just stuck to my Bible
I had no other choice now can I ask you
a question like and you don't have to
answer it if you don't want to but how's
your husband at this point you know I
think he's really confused cuz he's like
you're not the woman I married yeah you
know what I mean but I don't think that
he's he's so he's really gentle he's a
very gentle person and I don't think I
gave him enough credit as to how gentle
he was because when I was going through
what I was going through I kind of was
like why don't you get it why don't you
you know like see what I see see what I
know and it's like I haven't done the
things you did and I can't you can't
expect me you know what I mean and and
so and some of it was like I couldn't
talk to him about it because I knew that
I had gone too far W yeah so it was kind
of like a self-perpetuating
situation yeah it's beautiful that you
have a mate that is you know like there
still there through you cuz you know I I
kind of feel like I had the same
experience when when God used my wife to
get me out of my situation um I was
freshly married and that transition
happened and played out with my wife and
I don't know if I would have maintain
the course if I didn't have that other
person with me you know and so sometimes
it really takes that you like I I
there's there's no better way
to evangelize than in your character
yeah just living it yeah and and so you
know my niece like she here my husband
and I were thinking oh you know we're
going to save her get her out of crazy
New York and get her on her track you
know to medical school and I had no idea
God was going to use her wow to turn me
around to be that anchor and and to this
day I mean we're like sisters you know
um and uh love her dearly in fact I just
have to give her a shout out because she
actually um is in her third year of
medical school now beautiful very
promising career and she discovered a
potential cure for pancreatic cancer so
the Lord is using her so look out for
her anyway I love you said about that
she didn't judge you though like we're
you know I when I share my testimony I'm
always talking about that you know I
looked on Gothic and pentagrams and so
many Christians probably walked by me
and said he's not going to get it you
know and and when I did start studying
with Christians they could have walked
in my house I was I was a self-
professing Christian still drinking
daily smoking living with the one I
wasn't married to wearing huge
earrings and they could have come in and
said you need to pour that out you two
need to be married and then I said get
out of my house who are you but they
came in they were like let's study
doesn't matter if I had a beer in my
hand let's study let the word do its job
let the Holy Spirit do his job and they
just continue to study you want to come
to church can we have Bible study in
your house and and it was the words like
a sharp two-edged sword and it changed
my life I started seeing scripture be
sober we're in the last days I was like
I need to be sober right get married you
know so yeah I mean God literally showed
me the value of the world when it got
shut down what I found was that you know
I had exalted myself feeling like God
blessed me you know I have all these
things because God blessed me and now I
realize I had these things because I
pursued him pursued them and I had these
things because I put them ahead of God
and so when Co struck he shut it all
down and he made me see the value of
everything
you know the Louis Vuitton the Diamonds
the the Mercedes G wagons the you know
all of it was empty meaningless just it
could not save me it could not put me on
any other
plane no and so it was like this it it
was it was hard but it was necessarily
necessary and I'm so grateful God is
amazing beautiful wow beautiful that is
a wonderful story thank you so much for
sharing it with us for being so
transparent about even some of those
hard difficult trials and stuff but if
you guys were blessed by this story
please give it a thumbs up and share it
with with all your family and friends
because there are so many people
Christians included who are making these
small compromises that seem like hey
this is just about stretching or hey
it's God's making my dreams come true
but here's living proof of where that
road leads and she doesn't want other
people to go down that road and there's
even uh you hosted a series called wolf
and sheep's clothing you can find that
on with the Dare To Dream on YouTube and
there's a lot of uh shows coming out
about this very subject about the subtle
deceptions of the enemy and Mike's even
one of my guests I am actually a guest
on there so check those out and please
remember to like and share this if you
guys want to support this ministry you
can do so by going to little light
studios. tv/
donate and you can do so by going to
lightwear do shop where you can find
some really cool t-shirts that are just
a cool conversation starter to share the
WT you wear your witness and share the
gospel with complete strangers but we
love you we thank you and we'll see you
next time on LED
live if you're looking for a way to
spruce up your wardrobe this year check
out lightwear Dosh shop it's a
christian-owned apparel company with the
belief that we are all walking
Billboards one of the best ways to share
your witness is to wear your witness
these conversation starter designs are
the perfect way to look good while
shining your life for Christ for a
limited time use promo code love for 15%
off your entire order that's 15% off for
new clothing for you and maybe a gift
for someone special so go to lightwear
do shop and remember use promo code
[Music]
love